This is Tina, and she's competing for a
chance to win $100,000
and this golden ticket, which gives her
access to an entire year of guidance
from me and the team behind my $250
million per year portfolio. She'll have
the next hour with me, where she'll
explain her business, and at the end,
I'll decide if she'll scale or fail. If
she's chosen to scale, she'll move on to
the finale for a chance to win the grand
prize.
My name is Alex Hormozi, and this is
Scale or Fail.
>> [music]
>> My name is Tina Sue, and I help parents
of children with autism, ADHD, and
speech [music] delay. The reason why I'm
here to get help is because I know that
this mission is so [music] much bigger
than me. It is my vision that in my
lifetime, through this work, getting it
out to as many families [music] as
possible and having so many examples of
children that are healing, so we can
change the mainstream views on how
autism [music] is treated.
>> Hi.
>> Hi. How's it going?
>> Good. Amazing.
>> Excited?
>> Yeah.
>> Ready to rock?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> Yeah.
>> Tell me about the business.
>> My name is Tina, Tina Sue, and in the
last 12 months I did $770,000,
and $555,000
is profit.
>> Amazing.
>> 72% profit margin.
>> And you helped a bunch of families.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, what do you sell? How do you
make the dollars work?
>> Yeah, so my core product is called Hi
Mama.
>> Okay.
>> And it's a group program that helps
children [music] who have speech delay.
So, for example, non-verbal kids to
speak their first words.
>> Okay.
>> While also at the same time healing,
reducing of autism symptoms as well.
>> Okay. Got it. And the offer you sell is
2,500 bucks a year?
>> Uh the offer, so the Hi Mama program is
2,500.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And it's for the year with a 3-month
intensive in the beginning, 9 months of
aftercare.
>> Okay.
>> So, once a person is in the program,
then I sell them on to the all-access
pass, which gets them every cohort of
High Mama the 3-month intensive.
>> Cool.
>> So, they can stay in the energy and they
can continue
>> Cool.
>> to move on to the next level of their
children's healing.
>> What do you think stopping you right
now?
>> Me?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> So, I am doing everything.
>> Mhm.
>> Um I just like I can't let go of
>> You're so busy.
>> so so I have like every single Instagram
conversation. This is how I currently I
don't do sales calls. Uh and I'm in
every piece of marketing. I'm in the
delivery.
>> Yeah.
>> My team handles customer service, but
I'm often in that as well. So, just I
have my hands in everything and at the
end of the day I just don't have time
for anything. [music] So, low-hanging
fruits just doesn't get done.
>> Yeah.
>> Understood. Okay. Why does solving this
matter? Why is growing this business
important versus just staying where you
are and making 500 grand a year?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um
I mean, it's it's it's not about the
money. Um before starting this business,
I had another business and I still have
that business and [music] I had
developed that other business
you know, from nothing like when my son
was a baby between the hours of 8:00
p.m. and 2:00 a.m.
>> Savage.
>> I grew that all the way to $20 million.
>> Amazing.
>> And I had that business when this
happened with my son. And so um so my
son used to have autism, ADHD, and
epilepsy. And [music]
we had done everything conventional
medicine told us to do.
>> Mhm.
>> All the conventional therapies and
medication.
>> Mhm.
>> And [music] my son got worse and at he
was when he was nine.
>> Yeah.
>> The last [music] of his ADHD
>> Mhm.
>> I'm going to cry. Okay.
>> When he was nine, the last of his ADHD
medication stopped working. He had been
on seven at that time.
And they were ready to move him on to
antipsychotics.
>> Yeah.
>> And he stopped [music] sleeping and it
was just hell.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um
>> And so, you wanted to fix it?
>> And then somebody like just recommended
it's like, "Hey, look into holistic
change what you're eating and the
environment and so I went on this like
holistic journey to helping him.
And
in two years
>> It's okay.
>> Um
>> [music]
>> in two years all of his
symptoms of autism, ADHD, and epilepsy
went into [music] remission.
>> Awesome.
It's amazing.
>> Yeah, and then when he got better
I was like I have to do this.
>> Yeah. Well, congratulations. You did it.
Now you're helping people out. You're
making money doing it.
>> Yeah, so I had to like I just paused
from my other business and like just
went all in and just I just go in with
the attitude [music] of I'm on year
four. I just go in with like I didn't
even look at the numbers. I'm like I
don't even care. [music] I'm willing to
work for free
cuz that's how I started my first
business is literally, you know,
>> [sighs]
>> So, we're going to You can big exhale.
You're good. There you go. You're good.
[laughter]
>> not what I planned on saying.
>> You're fine. Don't worry about it.
You're good. I'll probably challenge you
on a couple things around like the
numbers and making money because I'm
sensing that that will limit the amount
of people that you can help because on
some level and you can correct me if I'm
wrong, it feels like you may have
equated like maybe charging more having
upsells or even having a more
standardized sales process with bad. And
I I don't think that that's going to be
the case and I think the more we can
structure some of these things and know
all of the numbers of the business the
more families you're ultimately going to
help.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay, I'll ask this question but I'm
pretty sure I know the answer.
>> Okay.
>> Do you think the business model as it
currently stands will scale?
>> How it is today probably not to the
scale I would want.
>> Okay.
>> But but it can scale to my goal.
>> Okay, so you're open to changing some
things.
>> I'm open. Yes.
>> cool. Let's do it. Let's rock.
>> Wow, Gino seems to be extremely genuine.
Her The of business is needed. [music]
>> I wanted to make it clear that I'm not
in it just for the money.
>> Being a mom myself, I definitely related
to that goal for her and how she's
helping so many other families.
>> I think we have a a similar goal of
helping people and so I I really like
that. I have no doubt that what she's
doing is is going to scale incredibly
well because of the market that she's
in.
>> So, [music]
we're going to fix this in standard
fashion and by standard fashion, I like
doing things back to front.
>> So, we'll fix offer
and then we'll fix the conversion
process and you're like, how's this back
to front? Well, this is the thing you
deliver, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Um and then we'll go to traffic. Okay?
This is kind of our our three-step
approach. Okay, so right now, you
currently don't have like a formal pitch
or webinar that you go through. You do
like a three to four hour like Monday
thing.
>> Yeah, and it's only just because I have
resistance to creating webinars.
>> Yeah, why?
>> Um
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> I just I don't want this to be
sorry for saying this, but like bro
marketing. Like I don't I don't want
people to feel sold to.
>> Mhm.
>> Um so
>> People only feel sold to if it's bad.
>> Oh.
>> A good selling
>> Yeah.
>> feels good.
>> I tried working on a webinar for like a
few weeks and I just like couldn't get
>> about how many things you've bought over
the last month.
How many did you feel sold to?
>> That's true.
>> Probably not many.
>> Yeah.
>> And every one of those purchases,
somebody for sure thought about how to
get you to buy.
>> Yeah.
>> It's just they did a good job.
>> All right, so just from a belief
breaking perspective, I agree with you,
should not sell poorly.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you should sell well.
>> Yeah? Okay. So, fundamentally, what's
happening is you're probably doing over
three to four hours covering the points
that could be covered in 45 minutes
and you just don't want to be as
structured about it. And if you're just
structured about it, your value per
second will go up for the for the the
parent.
>> Yeah.
>> And if your stated goal is that you want
to help more parents,
having the expectation that they're
going to wait two, three hours before
hearing about how you can help them um
is doing a disservice cuz you're losing
half of them anyways. So, like I think
that does them a disservice
>> Yeah.
>> because of whatever belief that you have
about selling poorly.
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
>> So, I think from a this is me actually
getting into conversion, but I'll put
this here, which is
structured
webinar.
And I think one of the things that holds
a lot of people back with webinars is
they think that like webinars have this
very specific
>> Yeah.
>> language pattern. It's No, it's just
it's really clear communication. It's
Let me tell my quick story so that I
have some reason why you should listen
to me. There's going to be a big promise
right before that. That's what you start
with, which is like why the hell are you
here? What it like why is it worth
staying on?
Right? Who am I? And then you say, this
is the main thing that we're going to
talk about, which is then the the call
it your your core you showing what you
shared here was your kind of core
transformation that you went through.
This is the old way, new way. It's a
very classic pitch.
Um I used to do this, this didn't work,
and then I discovered a friend of mine,
guru comes in, shares the secret
knowledge, which was that holistic was
the way. I implemented the stuff, and
then I got this great outcome both
internally and externally. It was
amazing. But it didn't just work for me,
it worked for X, Y, and Z as well,
because then we're going to hit the
different avatars that come up. And so,
the big three biggest concerns that
people have about this is problem number
one, problem number two, problem number
three.
And then you just systematically break
down each of the three problems. And
with each one of them, you're going to
follow a
what they think.
They think this, right?
And then you're going to say
why wrong?
>> [snorts]
>> Why that's not true? Like I used to
believe this, it's not true.
What's right?
And then proof.
And proof can be anything. Proof can be
stats, it can be stories,
um anything that just proves the point
and ideally as many forms of proof as
you can.
>> Okay.
>> Okay? So, if we can just take our 4-hour
marathon and turn it into a 45-minute
more structured presentation with slides
that has visuals to support because some
of them are listening within the
background, all these other things. If
you can have it more visually
stimulating, you'll get a higher
conversion rate. Cuz right now I think
you actually have an avatar that's in a
ton of pain and wants to buy cuz you're
converting like 9% right now, which I
think you could probably convert double
that because you're also selling to a
warm audience. And if you want to scale
it, which you're saying you do,
you have to sell to a cold audience. And
so the ads that you're running right now
are pretty much just targeting your
existing people since most people are
coming in already know who you are. So
we can't sell to people who already know
who you are. You have to sell like they
don't know.
And then you will sell people who don't
know you. But if you sell only like
you're selling to people who do know
you, then no one who doesn't know you
will buy.
>> Got it.
>> So it makes sense? You got to sell like
it's cold to warm and it converts
everything. If you sell like it's warm
to everyone, you'll only convert warm.
>> Got it. Got it.
>> Okay. From an offer perspective,
>> [sighs]
>> do you know what your upsell uh
percentage is from the back end of the
front end?
>> 10.
>> So 10% of people are taking the second
offer?
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm. Any reason you don't just do
6-month and have it recurring?
>> That's a good I I've thought about that.
>> and three. Like three months of
intensive, three months of
>> aftercare.
>> aftercare whatever. And so we want to
make the actual conversion to aftercare
before aftercare comes up.
So this is also a conversion thing, but
sell
upsell
during intensive three months. All
right. And ideally ideally you want to
sell at the halfway point
and then at like the two-thirds and then
you do a last chance
at the end. So right now you're only
selling here.
You want to sell here and here as well.
The more times you ask the more likely
they are to take the purchase offer. If
you sell only at the end typically and
you're not even selling, you're like
kind of mentioning it.
>> mentioned it.
>> Right. If you actually if you were
actually just only sell, you'd usually
get about a third. So you're getting
less than that, which is if you just
wait till the end.
>> Got it.
>> If you wait if you go to the halfway
point and the the two-thirds point,
you'll be able to get like half or more.
>> Got it. Got it. I actually sell most to
the people in the aftercare. So when
they're done closer to the 12 month.
>> You want to sell them when they're hot.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz everyone cools off over time. So you
want to sell when the pain is pain is
still elevated and they're and ideally
from a buying perspective, you want to
sell when they're mid-decision, not
making a new decision.
So, they're still in flight and you're
like, "Hey, let's just keep the party
going." Not, "Okay, we've finished that
thing. Now, do you want to start the
It's a It's a different It's a heavier
sale." And about a third of people will
take that offer, but you can get two
thirds or more if you sell during the
process.
>> Got it.
>> People are always scared of that cuz
they're like, "What's the I'm not done
yet." It's like, "It's okay. They've
already gotten value."
>> paid. I don't want to
>> It's not like that. It doesn't work that
way. If you go for run a marathon and
you buy shoes and the guy's like, "Hey,
do you want, you know, one of those tank
tops to go with it and an iPhone band?"
You're probably like, "Well, well, I
just bought. I'm not buying anything."
It's like, "No, you're still in the
You're still in flight, right?" Now, if
you finish the marathon race and they
say, "Do you want an an iPhone thing for
your wrist?" You're like, "No, I'm I'm
actually pretty good."
You know what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Um
Okay. So, from the offer itself, I think
I think we go $2,500.
Uh basically bi-annually. Hopefully I'm
saying this right. I think it's
bi-annually. If it's not, I'm sure
someone in the comments will correct me.
Okay. So, during the launch, does
everyone buy through checkout?
>> They can buy through checkout, but a lot
of them
>> Do they?
>> Uh about 30% do.
>> so a third of them do. So, what I want
to do, and this might sound like a
little little wild,
>> Yeah.
>> is I want you to have $2,500 checkout
price.
>> Mhm.
>> And want to have a $3,000
uh one-on-one price.
So, if I have to talk to you one-on-one,
it's it's $500 extra. And it's just
because if I were to charge hourly for
me consulting with you, it would be $500
an hour.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, I'll only charge you for 1 hour
um to do that, but
this is if you're like on the fence, let
me just already cover all these issues.
Now, I think part of the reason that
you're getting all these questions is
you don't have a structured webinar.
So, you're not having a structured FAQ
part, right? Which then this is going to
go to conversion. What I want you to do
is if you look at all You already have
all the DMs categorized, right? Or you
have like a big data set of all the all
the DM conversations you've had, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I want you to take call it every single
bucket of of FAQ
>> Mhm.
>> and I want you to review it at the end
of the webinar. And I want you to do it
is just pull the question behind you or
pull it up on the screen and then answer
it.
>> Answer it live.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay.
>> Because because they have the same
questions.
>> Yeah.
>> There's there's no new questions.
There's no new questions.
>> Yeah.
>> So the only reason that like you have to
do this one-on-one is and it's wasting a
ton of your time is we're just not
handling it. Just handle it up front.
So when we have our think what they
think we have our point, you know, intro
our promise
your intro which is your story
origin
and we have point one, two, and three
of the webinar
>> Mhm.
>> then you have your offer
and then you have your FAQ.
>> And then how many questions?
>> As many as there are.
>> Okay.
>> Just think about buckets. Like I mean
there's there's probably six flavors or
eight flavors or nine Whatever how many
questions there are like you answer all
of them.
>> Yeah.
>> As long as they're on, keep answering.
>> Okay.
>> But
>> Cuz you're used to doing three or four
hours. So like you just keep answering
questions. I'm dead serious. Just keep
answering questions. If they're still
on, keep answering questions.
>> Yeah.
>> But answer the ones that you already
know that represent the big like answer
it in in order of greatest percentage of
questions.
>> Okay.
>> So it's like the majority if I had only
pick one question to answer it'd be this
one and it's going to be 40% of people.
And my number two most asked question is
going to be this which is 25% of people.
And then my number three and then it
goes into the long tail.
>> Got it. Got it.
>> Okay?
>> But the problem with like having the
live parents come here versus my
three-four-hour thing is because they
take a long time and it could be like
I'll invite up to eight parents.
>> Uh-huh.
>> But that might be my own problem. But
cuz that could drag that that could drag
this on like
>> Oh that's cuz you're doing like Zoom
calls. Not like and you're getting 10%
of those people to buy?
>> 10% that come live buy but every time
>> That's insane.
>> Even outside the replay for the
three-four-hour thing, if someone
watches it and they can truly afford it
>> Yeah.
>> they'll they'll reach out to my in my
DMs and be like can I buy? Can I get it
now?
>> Yeah.
>> So this is how I'm converting them.
>> Yeah, we just need to basically your
delivery needs to become your content
and your pitches need to be your
pitches. You're kind of like muddling
the two.
>> [laughter]
>> Right?
>> Yeah.
>> Just sell when you need to sell, deliver
when you need to deliver.
And all that delivery stuff, that
becomes content which I'll get to in a
second when we get to traffic.
>> Okay.
>> Okay?
>> How does this feel?
>> Um this 3,000 one
>> to have a reason for them to check out
rather than having to DM you.
>> Oh.
>> If you want to have a call with me,
it'll be $3,000. I just add 500 bucks
cuz it it cost my time.
>> So so okay, so when they're checking out
they have these two options. They can
either do
>> you can just check out now and if you
want to talk to me
>> Mhm.
>> then it's $3,000. It's an extra 500
bucks and that's just because it's going
to take my time.
>> Oh, extra $500. Okay, got it.
>> I know this because everyone's and I
would just just state the fact and tell
the truth. Like I can't physically talk
to everyone and this is why you need
more people on those calls. That's why
it's like you're doing eight people at a
time. It's just a waste. Like let's get
50 people or 100 people on the call.
>> Yeah.
>> Have a structured webinar, answer all
the questions, make this offer, more
people will be willing to buy and then
it's like if you were not sure
>> If you're not sure and you want to talk
to me then
>> yeah, go ahead.
>> Okay. But what if it's like too many
people or is that offer there cuz less
people people won't
>> the the goal is that more people don't
want to pay the extra $500. Now if
everyone is wants to pay this, then
great. We raise our prices.
>> [laughter]
>> Cuz I'm like I don't want to do
one-on-one
>> No, great. Yeah, well but like that
they're doing it now for you're doing it
for free right now.
>> Yeah.
>> Right, so like let's at least get paid
for it if you're going to do it but the
goal is to incentivize people to do
this.
>> Got it.
>> And again, we're selling biannually so
automatically this whole thing is going
to switch because they're going to have
to opt out rather than opting in.
>> Got it.
>> Track?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So on the conversion process, I think
one of the big one of the big ones is
husband slash it's mostly female buyers,
husband's not there.
So I would just say give a three-day no
sweat
uh guarantee.
>> Okay.
>> Which you're legally have to anyways. Uh
so people get back out of a purchase
which is that if someone changes their
mind, they change their mind. Right? And
so just say, "Hey, no worries. Buy it
and if for some reason in the next three
days you talk to your husband and he's
like, I don't want our kid to get
better. I want him to stay the same and
get worse and like this be a problem
forever." If he says that, no worries,
just let me know refund you.
>> Okay.
>> All right, so that way it's like get in
and then that way um what we want to do
to counteract like potential refunds,
which is not going to be high anyways,
is you want to do your onboarding ASAP.
So, as soon as someone buys,
>> Mhm.
>> do the onboarding like the next day cuz
then the likelihood that they get cold
feet goes down.
>> Got it.
>> Just give them value as fast as you
[clears throat] can.
>> Okay, give value as fast as you can.
>> Cuz if they if they buy and then they
get on board, the likelihood they refund
is really low.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> so it's like let's just pull it forward.
>> Got it, got it.
>> Like they have 3 days to do it, but you
can deliver ASAP. Right?
>> So, on my live events currently, I'll
have something like if you buy while
you're on this call, there's a bonus.
So, should I take that out or
>> No, I mean you can do have a price goes
up and there's a bonus. So, this is
cheaper and you get more.
>> Okay.
>> Cool.
>> Yeah.
>> Now,
uh you have this $150 a month thing
for like one-on-one with your
>> It's not with me, yeah. It's my
membership.
>> team.
>> Yeah, with my coaching team.
>> So, if you're going to do that, you need
to make it like five times as expensive
or get rid of it.
>> Oh.
>> It's not priced right.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, cuz you have one-to-many and then
it's like for twice the price you get
one-on-one, basically. Right? So, it
should be like five times the price.
>> Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, it's like think like 8,000, 8,000,
10,000 is what it would be if I wanted
to have. People have the money.
I promise, they do.
And that money will allow you to scale
it.
>> [laughter]
>> It just it it like one on it just it it
the math doesn't math.
>> Yeah, but it's not with me.
>> No, I know.
>> It's with my team.
>> I know, it's it's it's it's not about
>> But it's like it's like support.
>> It's buying behavior.
It's buying behavior. So, either include
the like include your base level
support, which is what you have without
one-on-one.
>> Yeah.
>> And then if they want one-on-one, they
have to pay for the one-on-one price.
Many people everybody needs one-on-one,
everything.
>> [gasps]
>> But it just doesn't mean that everyone
can afford it. It's not worth it's
You have a responsibility to the
business.
And the business has a responsibility to
customers. But your responsibility is to
make sure the business survives and
grows.
>> Mhm.
>> And in order for the business to survive
and grow, it has to take care of the
customer. So it's a it's a it's a
circle.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. On the delivery part, so this is
on delivery a little bit. Um
you have this Telegram, right? That you
use cohorts in Telegram.
>> Mhm.
>> You can Are you familiar with AI?
>> Okay. So what I would do is I'd vibe
code um an agent that
searches the whole Telegram
>> Mhm.
>> uh and looks for past responses that are
similar to the question
and then suggests it to you or your team
and then you can check or exit and then
it sends it.
And that way you're going to
dramatically increase the leverage that
you have for each of your delivery
people.
>> So have the agent send it
automatically?
>> No, so basically you'll vibe code a
dashboard.
>> Yeah.
>> They don't even have to be in Telegram.
>> Like your team.
>> Yeah.
>> They have a dashboard. And then people
ask the questions so it's convenient for
them. But you make it convenient for
your team to have them all in one place
where it already has suggested answers
and they just reply or edit.
Single way faster.
>> Got it.
Okay. I can do that. Yeah.
>> How frequently are you running webinars?
>> Once every every time there's a launch.
So so that is
>> So this is what I would consider doing.
>> Yeah.
>> Once a week hold a webinar
>> Uh-huh.
>> for all the people who DM you and say,
"Hey, I'm doing a live thing with other
parents that way you won't feel alone.
Come attend." And then you can just do
the structured webinar once a week and
then mop up everyone that's been in your
DMs
>> Mhm.
>> and just send reminders to them to show
up. That way you don't have to go into
all these long conversations cuz you're
having the same conversation 100 times
in a row.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> And then you still do your launches
that's going to be the paid.
But your your weekly webinar can be
organic.
>> Okay.
>> That That feel okay?
>> only only for the people that are DMing
me or should I
>> No, I would just no. Should I message
the waitlist too?
>> Um I would just do For me I'd rather
just have all the people who are DMing
you. I'd use my waitlist for the
launches.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz it'll be like more razzle-dazzle.
But you're just We're trying to account
for like what happens in between. So big
picture, we're changing from our 3-hour
3 to 4-hour marathon to a structured
webinar.
>> Okay. going to follow this structure.
We can bring up the people live to do
the proof for each of the points if you
want to and that's only for your
launches.
We'll still use the same webinar. You
don't have to have the live people. The
upsell timing we're going to shift.
Right? Because we won't even need to cuz
we're going to we're going to be
bi-annually here anyways. So
this might not even be an issue.
>> you don't think it matters whether it's
6 month or 12 month.
>> Conversions say that I know.
>> Okay.
>> say.
>> Cuz I thought it was like oh you get a
year might be
>> Let me say it differently.
Do you want to have your tooth pulled
out in 5 minutes or 5 hours?
If you can fix your fix my kid in half
the time, fix my kid in half the time.
>> Yeah.
>> The bi-annual is still happening on a 6
month basis anyway. So that's automatic.
I still want to have a conversion like
push and reminder cuz I don't want to
bug people without them knowing. That's
not the goal.
>> Yeah.
>> But we want to have like it's like we
want to get the legal right to do it
here, but we want to have the
psychological right from here.
>> Got it.
>> track?
>> Okay.
Uh we're doing this pricing so that we
get more people to not DM you and buy
immediately. So it'll be a cheaper price
and a bonus if they buy on and if they
buy from you one-on-one and you're like
you don't get the bonus and it costs
more. Now if you're on the call you can
be like hey I'm not supposed to do this
but I'll give you the the bonus if they
if they ask for it.
>> Mhm. Got it.
>> We're going to vibe code delivery so you
get way more leverage from your team.
That's all good?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
And we're going to include this little
no sweat on the pitch and we're going to
add our FAQs in. That's all conversion
stuff. Okay.
Once we have all this, now we have an
offer that's already renewing. We're
renewing at the right point. We have a
structured conversion process delivery.
You got more leverage. We have our FAQs
covered and we have guarantees so we can
deal with the spouse issue. Now we just
need a more traffic. Okay?
So this is what I want to do.
So how many
So you have like 200 plus testimonials
that you've already captured which is
great.
>> There's like 200 I haven't even posted.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So you have post those. Um
how much Q&A is there in your delivery?
>> A lot.
>> Okay.
>> And they're the same questions every
cohort.
>> That's great. So um you're familiar with
Dave Ramsey?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> He people on and they say I should
probably spend less than I'm than I'm
spending and I should save more money
and he says that's a great idea.
If you did it for 45 years.
And so even though it's the same
question for you
the audience will not perceive it as the
same question.
And so I want you to take those Q&As and
you can probably have an AI editor just
cut it down. Worst case you can have an
offshore editor do it cuz it's a very
repeatable cutting process.
And I'd love you how many how many How
many Q&As would you say you do per week?
When I say I don't mean sessions, I mean
actual questions that you're answering.
>> Actual questions like on the live calls?
>> Yeah.
>> Probably between 30 to 50.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So
to me
that means you get 30 to 50 posts a
week.
Just by capturing and editing them. So
that all of a sudden
>> So So it doesn't matter like what we do
in the program is like being shown out.
Doesn't matter.
>> No, cuz it's going to be so it's going
to be bite-sized. You also have
questions that are coming in from
Telegram, right? And all those
questions.
>> Yes.
>> So the ones that get like uploaded or
have a lot of like engagement around it,
I would do green screen answers.
>> What does that mean?
>> So you pull the question behind you
>> Okay.
>> and you just talk about the question.
>> You've probably seen reaction videos.
>> Okay.
>> You just react to the question.
>> This is a question I you know like So
and you can have an AI voice read it and
then you respond or you can read it and
respond. Either way it's fine.
>> Okay.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah.
>> Just don't start with a lot of people
have been asking me this question.
That's a terrible hook.
>> Okay, don't start [laughter] with that.
Okay, got it. Got it. Got it. Got it.
Got it.
>> Okay. Um when you go on these other
platforms, if Instagram is where you're
used to converting everyone, push people
from those platforms to Instagram.
So if you do YouTube shorts, your
description should say DM me on
Instagram.
>> Okay.
>> If people are on TikTok, have your bio
say DM me on Instagram. That way we can
just funnel everything to one conversion
point. And then that pushes people to
webinar.
>> Got it.
>> Okay.
Now we should probably post the 200
testimonials.
>> But I really want to edit all of them.
>> Well, you for all of this you need to
get editing.
>> Yeah.
>> You have the profit.
>> You have the profit to do it and that's
not going to cost a lot of money. Now,
on
the ad side,
these content
become ads.
Because if we're if you're if you're
capturing
30 to 40 posts plus your green screens,
we're talking three, four, five posts a
day. That's per platform. So all of a
sudden you're going to like 20, 30 posts
a day per platform. You're going to be
all over the place. Then take the
winners from there and run them as ads
to your thing.
>> To the webinar.
>> To your launch.
>> Yeah.
>> To the wait list or the webinar?
Depending
>> Well, you have you're used to do the
launches I think we do with the ads cuz
you're used to doing that and that's
fine.
Um
this I just want to do fourth organic
for now.
>> Okay.
>> Just so it Now, if all of a sudden we we
find out like maybe this just turns into
a better cycle where you just run ads
every week to a webinar that you do once
a week, I'm fine with it.
>> Okay.
>> But this is your ad strategy.
>> Okay. So then this goes into the wait
list.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
Okay.
>> Uh what we found work is having like a
3-second delay
on the banner. So if you have like a CTA
um that's like, "Hey, register for
my next whatever, my launch." Wouldn't
say that, but my my thing. Um
just delay the the button by like 3
seconds. Like the banner on the on the
video.
>> At the end.
>> So if it the hook starts 3 seconds, then
put your CTA in and then it can stay
there.
>> Okay.
>> We just found that it gets it's higher
quality traffic.
>> Okay.
>> Just a little tactic.
>> How's this feel?
>> It feels good. But it's funny, it's not
what I expected. I was expecting like
higher setters.
>> No.
I don't even want you in the DMs.
Ideally.
>> I think you can get one one person to
really just point people over to Yeah.
>> You know, like, "Tina's doing this
thing." Da da da. Okay.
>> Yeah, you can also um hook up uh
AI now to just respond. So that's
already been linked up on Instagram. So
it can just respond right away.
>> that's one of the things when people DM
me, they're like, holy [__] you're a
real person addressing actual prob- you
know, like I don't want that. Them to
feel I'm managing people's feelings
again.
>> Yeah.
I don't respond to everybody who DMs me.
>> That's true.
>> I don't think. And if I did, I wouldn't
be able to help a lot of business
owners.
I'd be DMing all day.
So.
>> That's true.
>> It's your call.
>> Yeah. I could have a human do it.
>> Yeah. But they probably would like I'd
rather them just like I'd rather them
push to you and get a fractionalized
version of you than a whole percentage
of somebody who's not.
>> Got it.
>> Cool?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, this feels pretty
straightforward. We got a recurring
here. We need to structure the webinar.
We add these elements to the conversion
process. We expand delivery here, and
then we blow the [__] door off the
the front end. Now, one thing I do want
to address is that I think you said
you're self-sabotaging or something like
that. You making more money
means that you are helping more
families.
And you can help all the families who
can't afford it with this.
I have helped a zillion more people
business owners who have not paid me
than the ones who have.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's fine. I want that. Like I can
never I could never possibly
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
So I think if you can just you have to
just separate out the if I charge it's
bad because I know that you also had
some resistance to raising the price.
>> Yeah. I'm I mean, like one of my biggest
fears and I feel silly even saying it is
like I don't want people to think I'm in
it for the money.
And that's like
>> is in it to make money. The business is.
You own the business.
You can be in it for whatever reason you
want. The business needs to make a
profit in order to grow.
And if you want to help more people, it
will like you can help more people and
make more money.
>> Mhm.
>> Rather than or.
Because um uh my friend Taki says this
great thing. He says, either you can be
a starving artist or you can be a
soulless corporation and I think that
the beauty's in the middle.
>> Yeah.
>> And so if we make all this stuff, we're
helping lots of people for free, but for
the percentage of people that want more
help
there's a there's a for purchase option.
>> Okay.
>> Joe?
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> All right?
>> Yeah.
Easy.
>> Easy.
>> Easy. Okay.
>> All right.
Doable.
>> All right, doable. We did it. [music]
>> Hey Alex, I've got some updates. I've
been working hard implementing on all of
the directives and Alex tasked me with
creating a structured webinar and that
was the first thing I did. If it wasn't
for this show, if it wasn't for what
we're doing here, I don't think I would
have finished the webinar. It was so
painful and I have to say even though it
was really painful, it is finally
working. Like surprise surprise.
>> [laughter]
>> The times I'm spending in DMs have
significantly decreased. I was spending
about 30 hours a week just handholding
every person that comes through. It was
a lot of work. I've since created a new
structure where I'm in there for maybe
three to five hours a week instead, so
significantly reduced by 90%. Uh I've
created a structure where my team can
also help me as well [music] to ask some
of the initial questions and we just
direct everyone to the webinar.
>> [music]
>> All right, let's see where you're at on
the scaling roadmap.
All right, let's see where you at. So
you're at How many employees you have?
>> Uh not including the coaches, seven.
Including the coaches, uh 12.
>> Okay, so you're probably between these
two steps. So team five to nine and 10
to 19 in terms of prioritizing and
productizing.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So we'll probably have a
little bit of a mix here.
So if we're looking at product, you said
yes to anyone who would pay.
>> Yes.
>> Right.
>> [laughter]
>> And you're getting feedback from lots of
different people.
>> Yes.
>> And so we need to be a little bit more
specific about our product and you
already did cut one of them, right? You
had the picky eaters in the in the in
the the high mama.
>> Yeah.
>> We already We already made that
selection, right? So, you're you're
partially graduated from here. From an
unqualified lease perspective, you're
like, "Well, I want to help everyone."
That's what we make the content for.
>> And I got rid of all my lower payment
plans. I had a 12-month and an 8-month.
>> for us. I love this for us. All right.
And then same thing, we got rid of the
one-on-one.
>> Yeah.
>> Or we're pricing it way higher. Those
are options.
>> Okay.
>> Okay? Now, from a sales perspective,
this You have decent tracking.
But I think we might be looking over
here cuz now you're at this level. We
need to create sales aids and materials.
Webinar.
>> Yes. [laughter]
>> Right? Install weekly game tape between
CS, sales, and marketing. Basically
making sure that Well, your process This
happens more when you have a sales team.
So, you don't have to worry about that
as much.
>> Okay.
>> And the refund rate stuff, we're going
to make sure that we're going to onboard
a little sooner. That way, we don't have
to worry about that. All right. So, that
feels like this is about the the the
right thing. Spend more on niche-down
messaging. That's all these little
videos that we're talking about, which
then turns into ads.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that's what we're doing on the on
the marketing side.
>> Okay.
>> And [clears throat] we don't need to
worry about this one for now. And then
uh build proper CS playbook to onboard
and train team answers.
It's going to review all the past ones,
make suggestions, and they can just
approve.
>> Got it.
>> Does these feel like your problems?
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> If you're If you're watching from home,
you can fill out the form and it'll tell
you where you're at and gives tons of
videos for every one of these things in
a lot more detail. And it's free, so go
grab it.
>> I think Tina could scale the most
[music] out of everybody. Tina's
personality and the nature of her
business cuz
>> [music]
>> she literally solves problems.
>> If she continues to be led by her heart
and combines that with data, then
there'll be nothing [music] stopping her
whatsoever.
>> I'm like the queen of execution. Like
you watch me, the next 90 days like
>> Pressure's on.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> [music]
>> All right.
I hate this part. Um
So, I have to decide whether you scale
fail because that's what makes this
interesting. Um
before I tell you the answer,
>> Yeah.
>> um I want to say that
I think
this is a very right down the middle
will work.
The only fear I have is
the emotional side of it for you
>> Yeah.
>> of whether or not
you will actually be able to pull
yourself out because it is like you said
at the very beginning, it's a decision.
You said you have a decision to scale
>> Mhm.
>> which means you have to also have a
decision, which is that I'm not going to
answer every individual DM because I'm
going to take a local cost to have a
global [music] benefit.
And so, it's the same reason that, you
know, Steve Jobs, Elon Musk, or Bezos
can't respond every customer service
request on on Amazon or Tesla or Apple.
It's because they wanted to help more
people.
Um that is probably [music] my biggest
fear around the scaling it. The
mechanics of this are really
straightforward and I think that because
of your affiliate background, you can do
it.
And so, I'm very torn on this one
because
I just don't know enough about the soft
side of Tina of whether or not
>> Yeah.
>> you can draw the line.
Um
How big do you want this to be?
>> Mhm.
Honestly?
>> Give me a year. 12 months.
>> In this 12 months?
>> Mhm.
>> 500 new clients. [music]
And I have plans to do certifications
[music]
and more people. No, no, no.
Really?
>> [sighs]
>> God, I hate this. Um
>> I can execute. [music]
>> No.
Will you actually just do this and not
do anything else?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
Then you have scaled and you will be
scaling. All right, you'll move on to
the next round. Rock and roll.
>> Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh my god,
it's a
>> Okay.
>> No, I can do it. I can do it. I Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> You got it.
>> Thank you.
>> Little Ceasar.
>> All right.
Thank you.
>> You got to do this though.
>> I will.
>> Okay.
>> I will. [laughter] So, I'm going to kill
it. I'm going to crush it. And even I
was kind of offended when he was like, I
don't know if like you can separate the
emotions from it. And I was like, dude,
>> [laughter]
>> you have no idea. I can kill it.
It's done. It's in the bag.
>> It was a really tough one.
Um,
I think the big thing was that she had
done affiliate marketing in the past.
And so, I didn't think
she was going to get tripped up on the
technical stuff, which sometimes when
you're a smaller business, that can trip
you up. And so, I think she has skills
that will allow her to actually execute
this.
The big fear that I have is what I said
originally, which is like, I'm not sure
if she's going to emotionally be able to
do it. I was really torn on this one.
But, I'm I'm basically just going to
give her the benefit of the doubt of
like, will she execute this? And I'm
hoping that her global
need or desire to help people outweighs
her local need to
satisfy every person who messages her.
>> I was like really surprised at like how
kind he was. Not to say that he's not
kind, but like he just his demeanor,
it was really shocking. I thought I
would have been a lot more nervous, but
he was just so kind. And I just like it
really allowed me to relax as soon as I
just started talking.
>> All right. And so, that was this episode
of Scale or Fail. Stay tuned for the
next one as they all compete for
$100,000 and a year of working on
scaling.